eltern haften für ihre Kinder wer haftet
allerdings für Erwachsene die sich für
Kinder aufführen oder schlimmer noch für
Erwachsene die andere Erwachsene wie
Kinder behandeln und damit willkommen
auf dem Spielplatz der Berliner Republik
dort grassiert nämlich neben anderen
Viren auch das Virus der
Infantilisierung wir haben Videos auf
denen wir am Beispiel gesehen sogar
selbst die Bundestags Präsidentin Frau
Bars sich also wie eine Comicfigur zum
Affen oder zu essen macht wir haben
Fotos Videos von der jüngsten
Bundestagsabgeordneten Frau fester von
den Grünen die also Tanz werden eben
gesehen die grüne Landtags
Fraktionsvorsitzende Frau Schulze die
also mampfen lachend kickelnd durch die
fraktionsklausursitzung in Bayern führt
Politiker die sich in einer sehr ernsten
Lage wie Kinder verhalten mein dadurch
auch Sympathie Punkte zu bekommen und
wir haben gleichzeitig eine Regierung
die uns alle wie Kinder behandeln will
und mit diesen beiden Form von
Infantilisierung muss Schluss sein ein
Königreich ein Königreich für etwas mehr
Reife